الجرحى والقتله من تحت الانقاض محمد
الجزائري معنا الان من اعزاز محمد
المشهد لديك
نعم معكم
نعم في الحقيقه المشهد لدينا هو ان الفرق
الدفاع المدني ما زالت تعمل على رفع
الانقاض في عده مواقع و عده نقاط للبحث عن
عالقين في عده مناطق ان كان في اطراف
مدينه اعزاز ومنطقه جنديرس وعفرين
وترمانين ودائره عزه ومناطق عديده تضررت
وابني عددها كبير جدا تضرر جراء هذا
الزلزال وهناك عالقين تحت الانقاض المشافي
تناشد الاهالي بالتبرع بالدم لمعالجه
الاصابات العدد الكبير من الاصابات هناك
مشافي مشفى العسكري في مدينه عفرين طلب من
فرق الدفاع المدني عدم اسعاف الحالات اليه
لانه بات ممتلئا ولا يستطيع استيعاب
اصابات اخرى وبدات تحويل الاصابات الى
المشافي الاخرى في الحقيقه المشافي كل كل
المشافي في مناطق الشمال السوري في ريف
حلب
وتغوص بالمصابين والجرحى اعداد كبيره هناك
نقطه مهمه ان فرق الدفاع ومع هذه
العدد الكبير من النقاط التي تضررت تجد
صعوبه في تغطيه هذه النقاط كلاها
بالاسعاف او الفرق الانقاذ والبحث
والاليات حتى
فرق الدفاع المدني طالبت وناشدت الاهالي
ممن يملكون اي اليه ممكن يمكنها ان تساعد
في
رفع الانقاض والبحث عن الناجين ناشدتهم ان
يتحركون الى اقرب نقطه او اقرب منطقه
متضرره في الحقيقه هناك في مناطق بالتحديد
في منطقه الاتارب وتاره عزه
وهناك عدد كبير من الابنيه تدمرت بشكل
كامل فوق قاطنيها وهناك اسباب كبيره هي
الزلزال بالاضافه الى ان المنطقه تعرضت
لقصف كبير خلال السنوات الماضيه ومعارك
وهذا السر اثر بشكل كبير على البنى
التحتيه في المنطقه وهناك ابناء كانت
قايله للسقوط ولكن
الاهالي كانت تقطنها بسبب عدم توفر مسكن
لديهم ورفضهم السكن في المخيمات التي
تعاني بشكل كبير حتى الان فرق الدفاع
المدني تعمل في مواقع عديده واستنفرت كافه
فرقها وعناصرها للبحث عن الناجين وعن
المتضررين في الحقيقه حاولنا الوصول الى
هذه المناطق لنكون نظهر من هناك ولكن هناك
مشكله ايضا هي انقطاع شبكات الكهرباء
وانقطاع الاتصالات عاقه وكان عائقا لان
نكون من امام هذه المواقع ماذا عن الجرحى
محمد وقدره المستشفيات في اعزاز على
التعامل معهم
في الحقيقه المشافي تعمل باستطاعتها
بكامل استطاعتها لاسعاف الجرحى واستنفرت
ايضا كوادرها والممرضين والاطباء في
المشافي ان كان المشافي الخاصه وكان
المشافي العامه
حقيقه هناك اساسا في الشمال السوري النقص
في الكوادر الطبيه ونقص في التجهيزات
الطبيه التي
تعالج او تكون يحتاجونها الان في هذه
الازمات وفي هذا العدد الكبير من الجرحى
ولكن المشافي تعمل بما تستطيع بكافه
طاقاتها حتى انها ان الجرحى يتم علاجهم في
بعض المشافي التي اقتظت بهذه الاعداد في
الممرات الممرات المشافي او في غرف هي
اساسا غرف الاسعاف ربما امتلات فيتم
اسعافهم في الممرات او في غرف هي غير
مجهزه طبيا حقيقه
محمد الى اين يتوجهون
اين يجري ايواءهم في هذه اللحظات ما بعد
الزلزال وانهيار حقيقه المباني التي
يقطنون فيها
نعم الاهالي منذ ان بدا الزلزال كافه
الاهالي خرجت من بيوتها وتوجهت الى
الشوارع الاهالي الذين
المنكوبين تم اجلائهم الى بيوت اما
جيرانهم او اقاربهم او الى مساكن مؤقته في
المناطق في الاحياء ذاتها لم يتم انشاء
مراكز
لواء
المنكوبين ولكن تم
اياهم في المساكن والمنازل الاحياء
المحيطه بهم التي لم تتضرر بقوا في
الشوارع حتى ساعات الفجر ومن ثم دخلوا الى
منازل جيرانهم واقاربهم
والاهالي الحي
لتكون لان حقيقه لا يوجد لديهم بديل عن
منازلهم او لا يوجد لديهم بديل يلجاون
اليه في هذه الحاله ولا حتى مراكز مجهزه
مجهزه لاستقبال هكذا حالات